Một số tổ hành tình của tuyến đường thủy quan trọng này, tuy nhiên tiến độ khối phục lúc thông và sĩ xa trọng.
Theo cập chỉ hàng hài Los List, nhiều tổ vẫn trưởng giấn cổ thề về quy trình án nình từ phía ram,
hiện còn hàng chăm tổ mắt kẻ tại khu vực, kẻ thực ký suốt đồ bắt đầu.
Sẽ liệu tự công ty thao sỏi sự liệu tổ biển kép lơ cho thấy,
thất tổ bằng chuyển năng lượng chấm phần lớn với bốn trang 20 sáng tổ trở rộthông,
và nhìn lượng sạch biến mắt kẻ tại vùng vệ.
Tổ chức hàng hàng có thể kêu gọi các biển nhánh trong thiết lập cơ trẻ và đảm án toàn trung hỏa tập hàng hài.
Đồng thời cũng nhé mạnh u tiến hệ này là bảo vệ gần 2 minh thủy thủ đặc mắt kẻ tại đây.
Sở phân tinh nhận định việc bở lại hông mốt cười nhỏ quan trọng,
đối với thiết trường năng lượng khi giá rộ thủy dởi dạm mạnh,
sống mất quan trìm hai đến chi Minh tự đồ làm ý một thùng tuy loại,
sống quá trình phục khỏi hoàn thần thích trường và tối vệ tải trình luật sẽ còn phục thuộc và mức độ o định của thật lúc bắn và các cơ trẻ kìm sát li càng.